let's talk about this uh next story if
there's anything good that came out of
these midterms Nancy Pelosi will step
down as Democratic house leader finally
oh yeah all right Pelosi you're out
you're fired and uh okay she says she
wants to make room for the next
generation and uh it's it's just as bad
you know they're the same who's who's it
Hank Jeffries or something so I don't
know man are you guys
she's fired well she she's got to go
spend more time at home so Paul stops
picking up young men is that what he was
doing well it's a theory you know you
don't want to say for sure but maybe he
got hit with a hammer by one I heard by
somebody maybe possibly depends on which
underwear no no no they changed that
story
oh so it's just I think Paul was in his
underwear actually you bring a feral cat
in the house and you want it to be nice
but it's got a hammer you know that that
is sad too because I you know I kind of
get it we have bogus he's our cat yeah
and he was initially a stray and he just
he just pisses all over the floor all
the time and like there's no training
him he's a he's a he'll just like walk
and they'll look you in the eyes and
just let her let her rip so I get it
when when Paul brings in these guys and
he's like a crazy hippie and he's like
we're gonna we're gonna have a good time
cracking that with a hammer so he who's
who was the third party
that opened the door didn't it end up
being him yeah yeah but who was who what
were you saying before there was a young
man in his car so that's what I heard
that when he got arrested for the DUI
there was another man with him there was
a young man with him
yeah if I heard it was dropped I could
be wrong but that's what he was arrested
for right he was entertaining a young
man uh I don't know what they were doing
getting away from Nancy
who caught them wrestling
in their underwear yes it's a very
popular before you know a lot of people
are doing it over a hammer I I just it's
about time that she left though I mean
everything she was getting pretty
incoherent as well oh that's called uh
addiction to benzos yeah is that what it
is and painkillers because she has to be
on something she's on everything listen
to her when she walks it just sounds
like she's a drunk right yo for sure I
don't know people have said that I mean
her husband I think is he got in a car
accident well when Bine did the speech
and then she stood up and was like
dancing behind him when he was talking
about like people dying and then she
realized she was like oh this isn't the
part where I celebrate that's when I
realized like oh this is just a drunk
woman at a tennis club who doesn't
really know where she is like I think
the point at which she probably should
have retired that's why she started
talking like this yeah it's like okay
come on so oh five yeah no I'm not even
kidding he's like
so who who's going to be the next answer
who's going to be the next Nancy Pelosi
for them though I think it's this guy
what's his name Hank Jeffrey is that his
name am I getting his name wrong you
guys probably know in the chat
I don't know
some some election denying far left
lunatic whatever he denies the election
oh they all do they all they all did I
mean like every single Democrat denied
the election there was a there was a
Snopes article I think it was no I think
it's PolitiFact and um I'm not sure who
said it might have been uh lee zeldin or
something said that
Democrats have objected or or rejected
the the results of every Republican
president going back like several
decades or something and then they were
like mostly true mostly true and it's
like how is that not true they literally
do they get up and they say this is
illegitimate there was voters who were
disenfranchised or whatever and then
we're supposed to just act like
they're not lying when they call other
people election deniers or something
we do it one time and had one party at
the Capitol and everything that's what
they're waiting for but that's the thing
we're talking about eleven two is what
you're referring to we were talking
about it earlier you know that uh
they just the left acts like it doesn't
happen if if the hunter Biden laptop
stuff it comes out it's a mountain of
evidence we can all see it they just
plug their plug their ears close their
eyes and walk away and then say what are
you talking about I'm just talking about
yep and that's it so uh we're supposed
to engage with that I don't know this is
why I'm my attitude has kind of just
been like let's perhaps ignore them and
let them just play by themselves with
dolls in the corner or something I'm
with you yeah because they seem when
left alone they do a lot of crazy fun
stuff that we can just bring up later
yeah like fetterman yeah oh yeah
we elected Frankenstein you know which
I'm for by the way I want to say oh yeah
we're on the team awesome
so I think he's better than ours but
that's a different story is it like an
accelerationist thing well I mean we I
mean I think that's why a lot of people
voted for Trump in the beginning they're
like let the system burn down let it
burn down quick might as well put all
the crazy people and and you know might
as well put all the incompetent people
in there I mean they can't do worse than
all the crazy sociopathic people right
that's what I'm saying I was saying uh
antifa for Trump yeah you know I'm
telling these intimate people like hey
you guys are going out and throwing
bricks through Windows that's not gonna
do anything they got insurance it's
going to cost them a couple Grand
they're going to fix it that you do vote
for Trump right now I know Trump
supporters are like but hold down there
a minute Trump's going to fix the
country sure but that's not what they
think they think he's going to burn it
down right so just hey vote for him what
he got to lose yeah you're already
ruining the country
it's a sinking ship what are you gonna
try to save it yeah come on stop it so
uh antifa for Biden fetterman well you
made a great Point can he drive we don't
know I don't think federmen can drive if
they take your license for that yes
after you have a stroke in
Pennsylvania's not knocking that's
something ableist we're just saying a
fact
I mean a little bit like if you can't
drive you probably shouldn't be in
Senate I mean I don't think Nancy Pelosi
can drive can't you well not well her
husband definitely can not after like oh
yeah not after you know her morning
Mimosa oh right that's what I mean
basically she's old and she drinks too
much and so she's probably she's got
someone driving for her yeah she
shouldn't drive isn't there like a law
where they take your license after a
certain age or something yeah I think
well I think yeah they take your license
after a certain age yeah I'm pretty sure
I think it depends on the state yeah it
depends right right Florida you can
drive forever oh yeah well that's gonna
be crazy a lot of retirees down there
they're not going to entertain people
voting away their right to drive or
whatever but there are a lot of sad
stories of people who like their
eyesight goes and their their reflexes
you know reaction time goes down and
then they're driving a car and I don't
know man you got whatever shop well I
mean I know I know a crazy story back
from a neighborhood of a teenage girl
who got hit by an old guy and then he
rolls over her stops IT panics that he
runs something over so he reverses
crushed out like a melon oh no if he
just went over her she probably would
have had severe injuries but he crushed
her head because and so his life all
that happened license taken away no jail
oh but here's the issue with with jail
on that in that circumstance
is he of the mind to commit a crime or
is he just an old man who should not be
driving anymore and so the attitude I
guess from law enforcement was he's not
a violent criminal who's trying to hurt
people he's effectively disabled by age
so take his license away he can't drive
anymore but he's not going to jail for
that is that why none of these
politicians go to jail for doing
everything they shouldn't they're like
they're all we'll give him a pass there
was no intents they're just crazy you
know but that's that that is it often
it's like well there was no Criminal
Intent so you know no no crime committed
that's what happens with the human
trafficking they're like he didn't know
that old Rascal yeah yes it was a
Menendez right he went out with those uh
he went he went to that Island uh it
wasn't Epstein Island but remember the
story you guys know the story about
Menendez with the like where was he was
he in Puerto Rico or something and he
went to some Island and there were some
ladies and they're a little young you
know and then he got accused and the
response from his lawyer was well it's
not illegal where he was
oh okay yeah well I mean technically but
the lawyer said like even if he did do
it it's not illegal like he's in
different country I had to call my
lawyer
do you what
wow that's disgusting though I don't
know what yeah what are the laws well I
guess if you go down to Mexico there's
other laws
well yeah but there's some states I
think where like the age of consent is
16. yeah yeah Michigan's one that's
right is that really yeah he goes I know
I grew up there no I did
it was a good one to have on the books
oh high school not you're really leaning
into this
Dave's really going to have the calls no
I've been married for a long time you
look very cold I'm really cool do you
need a jacket I feel like he has AC on
in here I think it's I think it's
actually that nothing's on and it's like
30 degrees outside yeah I feel like
that's not tenable you do look shaky
we've got a Chihuahua there's a there's
a coat right there that is Michael oh
well there you go what is this you know
that's the thing about the air
conditioning in the office look who's
over here everybody turn the heat on
Luke is in a blanket oh thanks for
telling everyone my secret
yeah I got a blankie yeah
though I'm like real cold I think it's
kind of weird to me I mean I guess
you're wearing a sweater yeah I just
grabbed one from uh I don't know where I
got it I don't know why it's cold in
here I think it's because uh
the vent just pulls in air from outside
or something I think it is just yeah if
it's cold outside and you don't have
anything on that's what I do to sleep I
like it cold let's talk about that
that's interesting how do you sleep Tim
uh I put the AC to 32 degrees Yeah and
uh because if I don't a little Igloo
well so uh a while back I um
my fiance was dying of a rare disease
okay and so I misappropriated corporate
funds to try and research chronogenics
keeping her Frozen while I tried to find
a cure of course when he found out that
he came in with thugs you know through
the the the the chemicals and everything
splashed on me and now I have to live in
uh freezing temperatures otherwise I'll
die nice yeah yeah I once tried to uh I
once broke out of prison but you know
Batman stopped me that's cool that's
what Tim was trying to do now keep us
all Frozen so we stay on the show
forever I can't believe we're still
talking about this I'm a Mexican swam
here in the last can we can we watch a
movie can we oh man we gotta talk about
Black Panther yes so before before the
show I was taught like no one here saw
wakanda forever and I was explaining how
the villain is a is a basically a
Mexican guy who breaks into wakanda
bypassing their wall by going through
the river and they have to defeat him by
drying him off
yep like I'm sorry if that was a big
spoiler I don't know but just like it's
been a week now and it was you know one
specifically his back goes into flames
you said they have to dry him off and
then the final move is they they dry his
back off yeah that's killing an Asian
with a hard math problem thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time